CHRIS HAAS: Welcome to The
New Era of Service Delivery:
COVID-19 Digital Transformation.
Welcome, everyone, and thank
you for attending our session.
I hope everyone has been doing
well in these difficult times.
Today we'll be discussing
how the COVID-19 pandemic has
caused government agencies
to digitally transform
in how they deliver critical
public health and benefit
program services
leveraging Google Cloud.
My name is Chris Haas, and I'm
a strategic business executive
with Google Cloud, focusing
on our public health response
solutions.
Brandon?
BRANDON WILLIAMS: Hi,
I'm Brandon Williams.
I'm the innovation
strategy manager
in Eagle County, Colorado, and I
break things and sometimes even
fix them.
CHRIS HAAS: Great.
The COVID-19 pandemic
is impacting communities
all over the world.
At the same time, it has
inspired coordination
between public and
private sectors
and across international
borders on a remarkable scale.
The best way for technology
companies like Google to help
is by supporting the work
of public health authorities
to keep people healthy and safe.
The full impact of COVID-19
is still unfolding.
However, there are
already major changes
in the government and the
use of technology in aiding
pandemic response efforts.
Google is proud to be one of
many organizations partnering
with government agencies
during this period.
We are working alongside
government leaders
to implement new
solutions that help
them to enable remote workforce
to continue to operate normally
during the pandemic,
enable them to leverage
real-time and historical
data for pandemic policy
decision-making, and support
them for what's coming next
as our country reopens and
the economy jump starts,
including planning for future
phases of the pandemic.
The developing silver lining
is how these paradigm shifts
are affecting change
in how governments
deliver digital services, both
now and beyond the pandemic.
Google is helping governments
in a few major areas--
aiding agencies to handle
the rapid surge by providing
scalable systems and
virtual assistance,
enabling rapid application
development and deployment
of modern systems to manage
the pandemic benefit programs,
and implementation can
happen within days and weeks
versus months and years.
Also, leveraging AI and ML for
processing documents to help
automate the massive
amounts of paper
being submitted to agencies.
Our differentiator is
our speed and agility
to help the agencies bring
new cost-effective solutions
online, enabling states
to more effectively manage
constituent applications.
I feel there's one standout
theme in how our country is
managing this pandemic.
It's the speed of
our response efforts.
Local governments are
needing to break down
traditional processes and
modernize legacy systems
to ensure they are moving
as quickly as possible
to respond to the
rapidly expanding needs
of our constituents.
There is an expectation
of government
to operate as normal even
in these abnormal times.
The vision for our public
health response platform
is to transform the ability
of public health officials
to detect, evaluate,
react to, and manage
risks posed to public health
and safety by the pandemic.
We strive to offer a 10x
scale public health officials
ability to gain
situational awareness
across their entire environment
and to effectively engage
and educate the public at
multiple levels, whether it
be a specific individual
in contact tracing efforts
and/or to the public at large.
Public health authorities have
an incredibly important role
in responding to
COVID-19, but they
face many challenges due to
the scale of the pandemic.
In addition to organizational
limitations caused
by legacy processes and
systems which slow the response
efforts, there is
a flood of new data
but limited ability
to understand it
for decision-making,
if they are even
able to access and leverage it
at all due to regulatory and/or
privacy concerns.
And their operating environment
is constantly changing,
resulting in incorrect
or misinformation.
But there are many
opportunities for innovation.
By leveraging Google
Cloud's serverless Analytics
and AI/ML technology,
government agencies
are scaling their limited human
resources through automation
and reducing manual tasks to
identify and trace new cases,
predict the spread of the
virus, and effectively
engage and educate the public
on the response efforts
and real-time information.
We need to remember that data
warehousing is not a use case.
Data warehouse is
a solution that
enables higher order use
cases to make organizations
data-driven.
Organizations have started
using data warehouses
as the foundation for
operational reporting.
For example, monthly
standardized reports.
Government organizations must
increasingly enable their teams
to carry out ad hoc analyses.
This requires the use
of self-service tools.
Organizations are
also looking to mine
the right data stored
in their data warehouses
to perform ad hoc analysis
to understand correlations,
identify patterns,
and detect anomalies.
As organizations increasingly
aspire to be data-driven,
they are trying to harness
the rich data in their data
warehouse to create
predictive analytic models
and operationalize these
predictive insights.
This requires the data warehouse
to support their machine
learning initiatives.
Our goal is to help
government transform
into operationalized
decision-making organizations.
But the typical data
warehouse project
is fraught with
failure and millions
of dollars of wasted money.
Traditional platforms
are just not
capable of keeping up with
the new demands we have
on interconnected data needs.
At Google, we are
uniquely positioned
to support organizations in
migrating to new data analytics
platform technologies.
Why?
Because we used to
have the same problems
many enterprises now face.
We solve the data pipeline
inefficiencies and complexities
with a petabyte-scale
data warehouse platform
called Google Cloud BigQuery.
We offer the same analytics
technology to all enterprises
now with simple pricing.
BigQuery is fully
managed and serverless,
which means there is no
infrastructure to manage.
You can simply focus
on analyzing your data
to find meaningful insights
using familiar SQL queries.
And through our serverless
data analytic solution,
we eliminate the need for
systems engineering in the data
Analytics workflow so that you
can focus 100% of your time
on data analysis.
Governments realize
this innovation
by digitally transforming
through their use of the Google
public health response platform.
Working closely
with our partners,
Google has built a serverless
analytics and application
modernization
platform which aids
public health across major
pandemic response areas,
such as disease and
case management,
including active and passive
contact tracing, which
is a critical aspect of public
health pandemic response,
also tracking of
resources and logistics,
and engaging the community
through proactive outreach
and education.
At the center of Google
Smart Analytics platform,
enabling government agencies to
leverage their data in new ways
to accelerate innovation and
deliver critical services.
Integrating public
health response solutions
with Google's Smart
Analytics platform
enables customers to
easily scale the processing
and analysis of data.
Our fully managed serverless
approach automatically
takes care of performance,
scalability, and availability
requirements for
your data analysis.
With no infrastructure
to manage,
you can easily
leverage products like
BigQuery to analyze
gigabytes to petabytes
of data in minutes, not months.
Public health agencies are
now driving instant insight
from their data, empowering
professional and citizen data
analysts with AI-powered
predictive insights.
With a secure and
compliant foundation,
agency constituent data
is secured and private.
Google offers built-in
data protection at scale
to help protect governments from
intrusion, theft, and attacks.
Our multi-layer
security approach
across hardware services,
user identity, storage,
internet communication
and operations
provides redundancy
and reliability,
while our purpose-built chips,
servers, storage, network,
and data centers protect against
hardware-level intrusion.
Data is automatically encrypted
while in transit and at rest
and can only be accessed by the
authorized roles and services
defined by the customer
with audited access
to the encryption keys.
Within Google
Cloud, data is also
automatically
replicated and encrypted
for backup and
disaster recovery.
And at a basic level
in public health,
we can't even begin to have a
conversation without talking
about security and compliance.
So compliance, such as
FedRAMP, HITRUST, and HIPAA
certifications,
amongst others, are
built into the core of
all of our products.
No matter where you
are in the journey
to digital transformation,
know that we
have the capabilities to help
you solve your mission outcome.
Using maturity
framework such as this,
we will help you assess
your organization's maturity
and serve as your trusted
advisor in identifying
the appropriate
capabilities and use cases
you should be focusing on.
So let's talk
through an example.
Leveraging serverless and
AI-powered Contact Center
and chat bot solutions, our
Contact Center AI, or CCAI,
and Dialogflow
solutions are rapidly
deployable and able to
integrate with public health
contact tracing processes
to automate the human tracer
activities and reduce manual
case management tasks,
whether that be
engaging with people
via the phone or online chat.
Leveraging CCAI,
government agencies
can transform their
Contact Center
into an AI-powered
customer-centric optimization
platform which integrates
all valuable data,
provides real-time and
relevant information to callers
and agents, and turns
customer interactions
into actionable insights.
Here we have an example video.
Let's watch for a moment.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- First, we have a phone call
with a person which the Public
Health Agency would
like to engage
with for contact tracing.
Powered by Contact
Center AI and Dialogflow,
the virtual agent is able
to interact with a caller
to collect some of the needed
contact tracing details.
Let's have a listen.
[PHONE RINGING]
- Hi.
This is the
Department of Health.
As part of an investigation into
a confirmed case of COVID-19,
we are following
up with individuals
who may have had
contact with a case
while they were
possibly contagious.
We are calling to check on you
and discuss some public health
recommendations.
Is it OK to go ahead?
- Yes.
- Thank you.
We'll start with your name.
Please tell me your
first and last name.
- Brian McDonald.
- OK.
I have your first name is Brian
and your last name is McDonald.
Next, I'll need you to
provide your date of birth.
You can say something like
January 3rd, 2000 or May 15th,
1995.
Please go ahead.
- January 17th, 2000.
- Got it.
I have your date of birth
as January 17th, 2000.
Now, please tell me
your home address.
- 1951 East Spring
Street, Jacksonville.
- I have your address
as 1951 East Spring
Street in Jacksonville.
Are you calling in with
your own phone number?
- Yes.
- OK.
Right now, we are following
up with individuals
who may have been present
at John's Bar and Restaurant
on the 24th of May, 2020.
Were you present at the
location on that day?
- I was.
- A per--
- Next, the caller is
transferred to a live agent.
[NO AUDIO]
- --well-being.
Do you have any questions?
- Yes, I want to talk
to a contact tracer.
- Sure.
Please hold while
I transfer you.
- At this point, the live agent
is able to leverage Contact
Center AI's Agent Assist
technology to provide them with
live and recommended
knowledge-based responses
to the caller's questions.
- Hello, Brian.
I see you'd like to speak
with a contact tracer.
How can I help you?
- Well, thank you.
Could you tell me how my
privacy will be protected?
- That's a great question.
First off, we want to
thank you for calling in.
We take this very seriously,
and confidentiality
of your identity and
health information
is of the utmost importance.
Your name will never be shared
with anyone [INAUDIBLE] to,
and their privacy will
be protected as well.
Ultimately, privacy
encourages participation
in adoption, and
as a result, will
help us protect more people.
- Oh, that's great.
I see.
- Leveraging Google
Cloud's Contact Center AI
and Dialogflow, as well as
expertise in AI and ML built
into our speech-to-text and
Natural Language processing
solutions, we're able to
automate many of the human
contact tracer tasks.
Additionally, we are able
to automatically transform
this conversation from
unstructured to structured data
for further analysis by
public health agencies.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS HAAS: Here's the
high-level architecture.
At each stage, collection,
transformation, analysis,
and visualization, we are
using serverless technology
to deliver a modern and scalable
solution for government.
And this solution provides
powerful out-of-the-box
analyses and visualizations
which enables public health
responders to take
action immediately.
Throughout the pandemic,
we've been implementing
this and many other public
health response solutions
with government customers
around the world.
For example, the
state of Illinois
has deployed CCAI and Dialogflow
in their contact centers
to aid in their pandemic
response efforts,
both for contact tracing
and for benefit programs.
Additionally, the state of
New York has done similar.
Both of these states have
been hit hard by COVID-19
and are seeing success using
these types of solutions
in responding to the pandemic.
So circling back to
our functional overview
and the core Google Cloud
Smart Analytics platform,
let's take a quick look at
the visualization output
from this platform.
Here's an example.
Here we're leveraging
Google's Looker dashboarding,
visualization, and
business intelligence tool
to bring in, visualize, and
analyze all of the COVID-19
data that we're collecting
into the public health response
platform.
And remember, this as a
serverless environment.
The back end is
completely serverless,
and the front end dashboards
that we're looking at here
are also running in a
serverless environment.
First, we're looking at
the state of Colorado,
all counties, and all
data year-to-date,
and we're scaling it to just
the raw data population size.
Now we're focusing it on
the last two weeks only,
and we're scaling
it to 100,000 cases.
And we're able to drill down
even further into county level
data, and we're also able to
bring in many other public data
sets available within
Google's BigQuery solution,
including mobility, weather,
and other COVID-19 public data
sets.
All of this is delivered
to our customers
through low-maintenance
serverless solutions
so that you can
focus on analyzing
the data to make decisions
versus maintaining
the underlying infrastructure.
To deliver this type of
solution, as I've said before,
we use our Smart
Analytics platform,
with the core of
that being BigQuery.
BigQuery brings in
native capabilities
that allow you to do both
petabyte-scale analysis
in addition to integrated
machine learning
and GIS functionality.
And it is a truly
serverless platform
that allows you to focus solely
on your analytical needs.
Additionally, for
application modernization,
you can leverage Anthos,
which is our application
modernization
infrastructure that
can be used in a
multicloud environment
to deliver these
type of capabilities.
So with that, I'd like to
hand it over to Brandon.
He'll take it from here.
BRANDON WILLIAMS: Thanks, Chris.
Yeah, I think you
nailed it in talking
about the need for
public sector employees
to be able to do
complex analysis using
simple tools Natural Language.
We started on the arc
at the very lowest level
when COVID first
started spreading.
We are a international
ski destination.
And you can bet, if somebody
sneezes anywhere in the world,
we're probably going to
see it here at some point.
COVID was no different.
We saw it pretty early on.
Now, the complexity here
was we had limited testing.
Despite what was being
said, the test volume
was very, very limited.
We knew we had
community spread, and we
knew, because recovery planning
starts when an incident starts,
we were going to
have to build trust.
And in a pandemic, the
public is just as much a team
player as anybody sitting on
the first responder or emergency
operation centers.
They may serve in
different capacities,
but we knew that
trust and data sharing
was going to be key to being
able to get through this.
So the first thing we
did was very simple.
We used a Google Form, and we
sat down with our EPI teams,
and we got it out the door.
And this was really
just tracking symptoms.
Where we couldn't do testing,
we wanted to know who was sick
and who was not feeling well.
So we made it
mobile-friendly, Google Forms,
dumped into a Sheet, and we were
able to tie it to Data Studio.
The Data Studio allowed us to
take the information regarding
symptoms, the stuff
outside of testing,
and combine it with the
stuff that we were getting
from our private
medical practitioners
and other nonprofit
and other partners
and start to build a 360
picture of what our community
impact was really looking like.
It was important to us early on
to only create one dashboard.
We didn't create a
community dashboard and then
an internal
operations dashboard.
There's one dashboard,
and so we automated
as much as possible to make
sure information we were getting
was going right out the door
to the public in real-time.
And so, from that, we
got a lot of questions
from other communities on
how they could replicate it.
So we stood up a
quick Google Site.
We spent some time with
YouTube, created some templates,
and we made it available,
widely available to anybody
that wanted it.
And very quickly we saw
it adopted across counties
in Colorado and nationwide.
Now, that turned into--
thankfully, we've got a really
close working relationship
with the state of
Colorado anyway.
They've been a longtime
Google partner as we have,
and so being able to share
data in Google was natural.
And this spread up to
the governor's office
and across to the departments
to be able to figure out,
how could we do
symptoms tracking
and share the information
back to locals
in a very narrow sense
so that it was secure,
real-time information
for tactical level
at the local level so that
they could maneuver resources
and respond, but give the
state that strategic overview
and picture that
they needed to be
able to start
allocating and thinking
next steps in the response?
And so we worked
together with the state
and a lot of other
partners, and we
were very happy to be able to
launch the same kind of symptom
tracker we did in Eagle
County at the state level
to start to get
that 360 picture.
And that's turned into a much
wider discussion about how
we share data across the
disease prevention and disease
monitoring spectrum.
And so, specifically, it's
created a new normal of data
sharing.
We're starting to look at that
tactical and strategic levels,
being able to dump information
into central locations
so that we can
throw BigQuery at it
and extract the data in
Natural Language that's
unique to a geography
or a demographic need
and be able to share
that information securely
across a vast
number of partners.
But it hasn't been just Google
Forms and Sheets and Data
Studio.
We've seen an explosion in all
of the Office productivity tool
set.
Meet, unsurprising.
We used to be able to
get together and talk.
Now we have to do it remotely,
and so our data regarding
Meet explosion is unsurprising.
Where I think it is surprising
is in the changing adoption
rates that we saw regarding
Groups, regarding Maps,
and other dashboard
elements, Charts and Sheets.
And specifically
around Google Sites,
we've seen a real
explosion in stuff
we would have generated
in PDF or other reports,
we're now doing
dynamically in Sites.
And this is an example.
Here, we had a regional response
where we had our COVID testing
locations coming off of Google
Sheets, some other data.
We created a
mobile-friendly Google Site
that's simple enough
for my mom to use,
and we pack it in with a
map and contact information.
And that's updated
in near real-time so
that all of the
testing information
and how to initiate that process
is immediately accessible.
It's carried over into some of
the Just-In-Time training we've
had to do for emergency
operations center.
A pandemic brings in a lot
of partners, many of whom
have never stepped inside of
an emergency operation center
before.
And so to teach them
about incident command,
emergency operations, what their
job functions and roles are,
we stood up a Google Site.
We were able to educate
them with simple YouTube
videos, Google Docs,
Drive aids, job aids,
and be able to convey
information so that they could
be prepared when they first
stepped in to be able to help
and pitch in on the response.
It's helped us look at
our own internal planning.
Here is our equivalent
of an intranet.
As we moved to
remote work, we had
about 170 different
activities that
now needed to take
place without a VPN,
direct on any device securely.
So we moved a lot of
our processes to Google,
and now all of our
internal operations
are accessible within a
single landing page that's
greatly reduced complexity.
And it's given us
additional visibility
into usage, who's doing what,
what are the needs, where
are we seeing surges,
and being able to respond
to that accordingly.
I think one of the
more exciting things,
and you alluded to it
earlier, was Dialogflow.
Dialogflow in a pandemic, we've
got 40 or 50 different players.
Everybody is going
so-and-so deep.
The information fluctuates
on a constant basis.
And we needed one
way that people
could Natural Language
search to get information
that was important to them.
Dialogflow is a perfect fit.
In this case, in the
low code environment,
it took us eight days
from the first time
we sat around a table
talking about it to where
we had something deployed.
Was a very, very
quick turnaround.
And now we're able to respond by
still keeping Google Docs where
the primary players are updating
their information in real-time.
We scrape that and make
it available in the chat.
We've expanded
that beyond COVID.
As we're in wildfire
season, we're
now addressing fire restrictions
data, wildfire response
information.
And we're now on
a path that we're
going to bring all of
our government services
in so that you
can get to a point
where you can ask your
fridge whether your driver's
license is up for renewal.
I think this new normal
has brought together
a lot of lessons.
I'm really excited about--
I wish we would have
done it in an exercise,
but I am really excited about
the wider inclusion steps
that we've taken
horizontally and vertically
across local governments with
state government and this data
sharing effort.
I think keeping it
simple was important.
Now that all of our budgets
just got obliterated,
being able to track cost
avoidance and efficiencies
with tools that we already
have at our fingertips,
our staff has been on Google
for, I think, eight years now,
and so these were tools that
they naturally stepped into,
immediately deployed.
And most importantly, the
tools like that Google Form
for symptoms tracking,
we deployed that
within those
initial first hours.
And those were
designed by myself,
and the lead of the EPI team
sat down and hammered it out.
So there was no delay in
waiting for communications
or other designers to step in.
We designed it.
We deployed it.
And so I think that's really
key to moving forward--
deploying and iterating.
Being able to do
something like the chat
bot in real-time
where information
is changing so often.
And keeping that updated
with a lot of partners
has been invaluable in
coordinating our response.
Here, making sure
the public had access
transparent, accountable,
in real-time,
and being able to deliver
that in very short order
has been important.
Government sharing
is just too hard.
We need these recipe
books, a library
of customizable templates.
We've seen an explosion in
sharing across government
sectors to be able to
contribute to each other
to help in the COVID
response, and I'm really
excited to see where that
goes in the next step.
I am a true believer, and I do
believe government's awesome.
I think the future of
government work, like everybody,
remote work has now been
proven to be a reality.
So shifting into these
collaboration tools that
provide the same security access
on any device from anywhere
and being able to work
confidently remotely
and do so confident that
your information is secure
has been pervasive in every
single program that we do.
I'm really charged
up about the way
that leadership
has embraced this.
Seeing government
leaders think creatively
about using these
collaboration tools
and demanding things
like Dashboard
to make data-driven decisions
and change deployment
practices, sometimes even
in the middle of a response,
to be able to respond to those
community needs, I think,
is really exciting.
From a collaboration standpoint,
this has been unprecedented.
Having private sector
nonprofits and others
sitting in that emergency
operations center
and sharing
real-time information
to make sure economic
recovery is happening,
the community needs are
being taken care of,
and that we're prioritizing
cases for testing and handling
has been exciting.
I'm looking forward to where
that takes us in future efforts
when it's not a pandemic, and
I think low cost, high impact.
Nothing demonstrates
this better than being
able to look at the impact
that we're taking financially
from the lack of things,
like travel revenue,
and trying to project
what that impact's going
to be over the next
couple of years,
and moving into that
with a confidence
that we have a toolset that's
going to enable us to be
able to respond with the
same type of delivery
that the customer expects
in their private life,
and expecting government
to move at the speed
of the private sector,
and now we can do so.
I think one of the things
that's really come out of this
is that need for public sector
communities to come together.
And I'm so proud of the work
that we're doing with Google,
with our partners in the
UK, with our partners
at the state, local, and federal
level here in the United States
where we've launched a public
sector community that's
building those cookbooks,
those recipe books for copy,
customize, and deploy, no
additional cost, and the tools
that you already use.
And that and just
the conversations
that are having it, bringing
a face to the common
challenges that we have, and
we meet on a regular basis now.
And I'm looking forward
to bringing so many more
members in with so many more
different ideas and eyes.
CHRIS HAAS: Thank you, Brandon.
It's always a pleasure
to partner with you.
You're a great
person to work with,
a great team that
you have up there,
and thank you again
for presenting
with me in this session.
BRANDON WILLIAMS: Thank you.
Looking forward to it.
CHRIS HAAS: Thanks, everyone.